hi I'm RIA I'm a tasty producer yet
again I've been challenged to take a
common food and make it fancy here are
the rules you must completely use the
food given you can only add to the food
you can buy whatever ingredients you
wish the previous times both of the
items I don't usually eat or cook so
this time hope for the best right let's
see what's in it
[Music]
spam its shkoder II it's fuzzy
it sounds like comic I hope you like
it's like spam
[Music]
[Music]
like Volvo meet a path they award so
here's what I got
Parmesan cheese mozzarella cheese
breadcrumbs
why onion chicken broths marinara sauce
in arborio rice garlic lemon and parsley
from the pantry I got its flour white
wine black pepper salt and butter let's
get started make it fancy okay I'm going
to set up my station I'm going to get my
equipment and my special knife also I
chose low-sodium chicken broth because
spam is very salty so I chose arborio
rice this rice it's perfect for what I'm
making right now 1 cup 1 cup of white
wine
it seems like you'd like to
[Music]
I like using alcohol yes I'm gonna start
cutting onion my knife is a little dull
I have to take my lady to the spa maybe
after this year I'm gonna call another
half so sharper the knife less likely
you gonna cry and golly sometimes it's
difficult to peel garlic skin and you
can just remove the ender pearl and put
it in the hot water and it makes it easy
to peel so I want to just like do a
small means another of my favorite tool
aids scraper you can like scrape
something in a cutting board and easy to
transfer it's important to heat up
chicken girls going to melt butter and
saute onions you don't want a brown
onion you just want to make a
translucent so I'm cooking in a medium
heat gonna take about five minutes the
garlic and saute just fragrant about one
minute add a little bit more butter and
melt it I'm going to add rice toast this
rice until the edges a little bit
translucent my chicken stock is boiling
so I'm going to lower the heat I just
wanted to keep it warm and I'm going to
add the white wine bring it to a boil so
alcohol is a plate rice absorb all white
wine and it's become a good flavor so
I'm starting chicken broth one cup at
the time so rice is Rory absorbing
chicken stock you want to stir it
constantly because you don't want to
burn on the bottom I'm adding Parmesan
cheese which is very salty look at that
easy we're gonna add more I think it
need a little bit seasoning so I'm going
to add a little bit salt black pepper
lemon zest and a little bit of lemon
juice okay so we are going to chill this
in a refrigerator and they're cool to
touch and you want to spread in kind of
like Spain layer so it cool down faster
go to refrigerator now spawn time come
out did you get the sound so I'm gonna
just cut this very very thing it's very
easy to cut it's very soft I think it's
love and hate some people love it some
people doesn't like it at all so my goal
for this dish is everyone eaters will
love this dish ooh nice sound I want to
get the nice brown color yeah hi what do
you do guess what I'm cooking great are
you trying to make it fancy yeah make
these fun C's I'm not a spam fan I don't
want to shock anyone yeah yeah say I'm
just saying yeah I mean like I make it
delicious
don't ya you should come back and try it
what I make okay I'll do it
anything for you good luck thank you for
stopping by I don't want to make it
greasy so I'm going to bring sheet pan
and put some paper towel I'm gonna
squeeze lemon so this it's done and I'm
gonna just go it I'm going to chop some
parsley I have a pot of oil to fry heat
the oil until 370 I like a little bit
green
in it and it kind of have a nice fresh
flavor butter some spam and I'm adding
mozzarella cheese
oh my everything mixed time I feel like
this one's kinda a nice pink color gives
a nice pop to it and it's kind of pretty
right now I'm going to form them into
balls and I like ice cream scoop the
sides is even if you like anything round
it's kind of cute almost there now I'm
going to call them with flour egg and
bread crumbs so this hand it's just egg
and this hand it's just flour because
when you touch egg wash it's very you
know kind of dirty
make sure your rice bowls is fully
coated with bread crumbs my finger it's
double fine
final stretch heat up marinara
[Music]
this episode is all about found oil is
375 I'm going to start frying
you can fry like I would say 6 at the
time you just want to fry until golden
brown probably 5 minutes you just wanted
to make everything it's warm and nice so
cheese melts
you know crispy outside that's why
you're looking for so I got some basil
leaf I found I'm going to fry it for
decoration so I'm going to just try it
one for myself
nice do you see this look at that wait
in time so arancini is very delicious
sweets eating marinara so just put the
drop of marinara and and we are done
[Music]
oh very fancy don't you say that you
don't like fun I love this remix fan it
comes in a can
I'm not a fan but this is my jam mix it
with rice fried up nice but on to Basel
didn't think twice she had a fancy odd
that a dancing make it fancy a fictive
fancy maybe buzzing I think you like it
good very good
yeah you made it fancy see to make it
fancy I don't Jeannie you can break it
and observe it if you want to
[Music]
it's good ok do you want to do them no
thank you
[Music]
that's a lot yeah great did I make spam
confit
he made it fancy yay do you wanna dance
thank you for watching I hope you like
it and I totally encourage you to make
at home and if you make it please tag me
on Instagram and comment below make it
fancy
[Laughter]
[Music]